[Music]
all right those of you who can please
stand and join me in pledge
go
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic which stands one nation under
god indivisible with liberty and justice
i apologize representative dolan could
you please read the script before we get
started i did read the script but i
don't know i don't know how many people
heard it though
we didn't hear it uh we didn't hear it
online
i apologize let me do it again
as chair of the municipal accounting
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the poverty 19th pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to be electronic
this is the publication on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please out there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the
emergency order i am confirming that all
members of the committee can select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar
and through electronic calendar on the
general court website online
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271 3600 or email hc
at leg.state.
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rested
please note that all votes that attended
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking the
roll call attendance
each member states their presence please
also state whether there's anybody in
the room with you during this meeting
with the requirements of the right to
know
mr secretary uh chairman dolan yes
champion
here
is here
president trump
president
representative guthrie president and the
llp
representative
here lob
here at home alone
representative melvin here in the
elevator
representative
sir um
let me meet at the other end of the
house
you're at home my husband is in the
representative gilman
i am home in exeter in my office and i
am alone
i am present in my home office alone in
northampton representatives davis
i am present and i am in my home in west
lebanon and alone
representative
i'm
present in uh at my home in nashua and
i'm alone with my pooch
representative gallander
i'm here um in my apartment in concord
and i'm alone
i'm mr we have three other
representatives i'm going to call the
subs representative bridge
uh good morning i am alone in west milan
and i am here
representative fail
i'm here um
i have my roommate at the other end of
the house i'm in my home office
thank you and representative grafton
i'm here in rochester at home and alone
thank you
thank you everybody and welcome
we will be hearing uh three bills this
morning
bills 52 87 and 102
and then this afternoon after lunch
we're going to exhibit
those three bills plus the three bills
that we hear it last monday which were
86 and 88 all senators
will be executing six bills a second
okay any questions before we get started
saying done let's uh open a hearing for
senate bill 52.
do we have uh senator
avar or senator guida
uh here to introduce the bill
it's me senator evart yes um
lisa please continue the floor with
yours
thank you very much and uh hello
everybody on committee i'm uh for the
record i'm senator kevin average
district
12. i represent three wards in nashua
hollis brookline mason ranch nope
switching greenville
and mason uh and today i'm introducing
sb52
and i do have a couple of dogs in the
room and there's some uh
some very vocal birds outside so
please don't uh
be distracted if you will i'm bringing
forth this bill um
years ago
we we had a referendum here in nashua it
was in 1993
and it had to do with the spending cap
and the folks in in the city of
nashville were very concerned about the
the spending and
in their minds it appeared to be out of
control
and so they came up with a referendum
and it was voted for uh in in the in the
form of a spending cap
and uh over the years it was it was
honored and it seemed to be working
pretty well
um there were some
legislators in i think it was in 2011 i
think in the senate that
uh wanted to reinforce it uh statewide
because there's some people that have
tax cap some people have spending caps
we have a spending cap
and in the process of uh
trying to reaffirm what has been done
uh there there were some
in some people's minds some errors that
were made and it uh it basically caused
some trouble
for the spending cap
you know uh one of the things about
referendums is they're they really are a
pure form of democracy
you know and when the people uh get
together in in a town or in a city
a municipality anywhere and they put
something uh with the intent for it to
be enforced uh that is the purest form
of democracy and it passed
um
not everybody in town is an attorney and
not everybody uh
basically uh is a professional
politician or whatever but uh
they all did vote for this bill
and it did pass when i say all i mean
the majority
um
so the purpose of sb52 is basically to
reckon uh rectify an inconsistency with
rsa 49c 33 the
statute that states a framework for the
city's establishing a tax or expending
cap
the
inconsistencies involve two words and
this is where the rub is it's override
and exclusion
and basically to summarize everything uh
the supreme court reviewed this uh
recently because of uh
alderman
former alderman jan moriarty fred t
boone and paula johnson
who basically uh were very vocal that
the the spirit of the spending cap
wasn't uh
being honored
to present date so they brought it to
the supreme court supreme court said it
can't be
enforced because of these two words
and so
with direction of the of the supreme
court
and and senate council we redrafted the
the bill
as as you see as amended and we passed
it in the legislature
in the senate
and basically
the ultimate reason we've done this is
because people are concerned
that the spending cap is not being
honored
and so this reinforces it and we're
hoping that you basically see it the
same way that the senate does
thank you other questions
for the senator
yes
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you senator for taking my
question
uh
how does this change
correct the problem
uh well
are you looking at the uh the amended
bill
yes i am okay there's the the new
language and the amended bill
that
you'll see on line 15
um
principal payments or municipal bonds
debts capital expenditures which shall
be
by a supermajority vote as determined in
the charter
an ordinance and according to practice
that redistributes equitable budget
excludable budget pardon me
items from within the limits of the cap
budget to outside limits of the cap
budget shall be by a super majority vote
as determined
in the charter i think that basically is
is
the principal line uh also in uh line 29
i'm sorry 28
you'll see the new language uh involved
or interest in
principal payments municipal bonds debts
capital expenditures which shall be by a
super majority vote as determined in the
charter
an ordinance or accounting practices
that redis distributes excludable budget
items from within the limits
of the cap budget to outside limits cap
shall be by a super majority so
basically it's not saying that they they
can't but it has to be done by a super
majority if they're going to override or
the budget and it just reinforces
that
uh the the rob was is that when when
fred t boom and dan moriarty brought
this to the supreme court the the
supreme court said that it wasn't um
enforceable
because of those two words that the
override and exclusion uh have a
different meaning and so
this changes the language so that it
would reinforce the will of the people
as i just
read to you
please yes follow uh
is uh
is the exclusion something that's
permitted in the national charter
i don't have that information
available with me right now um
i don't know to be to be frank with you
and i think that there will be people
that will testify one way or the other
to that effect
i do know that uh because of the supreme
court ruling
uh
that there is an inconsistency in their
minds and so there this basically tries
to rectify that
well thank you very much
you are next is uh
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question um this may seem
like a simple question but it's a super
majority vote of what
of the city council of the voters at
large
the aldermen
thank you
let me let me follow up on that now uh
senator
that would be the national example what
about municipalities that don't are not
served by all
uh this basically affects where there's
a spending cap or a tax cap and
basically reinforces the tax cap i
believe rochester has one i believe
franklin has one i'm not sure about
dover but there are there are a few
others
and this doesn't affect them in in any
other way other than reinforces what
what the the senate tried to do in 2011
and and uh reinforcing
the the language in the will of the
people um
so
this does help out the city of nashua
though
no mr chair thank you i'll put my hand
down
wow
status
and you're still on mute
yes i just realized that i'm sorry mr
chair
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
it has to do with the wording on line 16
where the sentence is an ordinance or
accounting practice that redistributes
excludable budget
items
how does an ordinance redistribute
budget items it seems to me that an
ordinance is something quite different
than an accounting practice and i'm just
i'm looking for some kind of an
explanation of
how do you know if the if the will of
the people is to pass a certain
ordinance
whether that ordinance has
financial implications tied to it that i
don't understand how you would know that
i live in a city myself
and
we pass ordinances all the time and
they're not necessarily attached to
accounting practices
well i would think that
uh we have bills in the senate and in
the house some have a financial um note
to them and some don't
ordinances some will some won't
okay uh next uh representative benjami
thank you mr chair thank you senator
eward for taking my question
you did mention that it's going to
affect
nashua
directly
and having lived in nashville for 30
plus years i remember the
spending cap and then the
trying to override it and
super majority we have 15 aldermen
super majority what does what
two third majority versus super majority
what's the difference
are you alluding to two third majority
or the super majority
supersede the two third majority
um
i don't know how to answer that surprise
let me jump in
uh senator do you know if the net
nashville charter defines what a
supermajority is for the ultimate
right offhand i don't
okay we'll be getting some major notches
mayor dodgers soon i'm sure he will
probably know the answer to that quote
thank you
okay representative matthew eurek
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question i understand that
the intent of this bill was to clarify
uh clarify the definitions override
versus exclusion
does the addition of super majority
do that or does
including the word excludable do that or
are they complementary or or not
that i would defer to the attorneys that
helped draft this uh i i believe that
they they can answer that a little
clearer than i can i just understand uh
the the simplest form of this bill
was to to clarify those two words and to
provide
that the the town or the city of
nashville would be able to enforce its
uh its original charter by by making
these two
two corrections uh
okay it's
it's that's yeah
yeah i don't to over complicate this
bill it just it's very simple it's the
will of the people they voted for this
they did vote for it by a referendum
and uh
and the people were outraged that the
uh
the bill has not been reinforced in late
as of late
and so it went all the way to the
supreme court
and this is their direction as to as to
what we need to do to for the will of
the people
to be enforced
thank you senator uh
representative porter your follower
yes i do have another question thank you
mr chair and thank you senator again
when was the nashua charter established
do you know that i believe it was in
and when was the tax cap
tax spending cap
referendum held
i that i don't know i do know that there
was some legislation in 2011 that was uh
aimed at trying to support
the the intent of the spending cap and
the tax cap statewide
and uh
through
the wisdom of the the senate and uh i
believe senator bradley was part of that
that conversation
uh they overlooked uh that this might be
an issue and that's why uh it's brought
before you today
again and it had been reinforced it had
been
abided by
for many years and it seems as though it
uh
it is not at this present time
so uh
i don't know if that answers your
question or not
it does but i have a follow-up effect
all right mr chair exactly
okay so
it was vote it was voted on in
93 you said or 11.
the tax cap the the referendum that the
spending cap the referendum was uh
adopted in 1993. it was uh
uh the state uh tried to fix it so that
it could be reached
in 2011.
and uh
could it come up for a referendum vote
again
in the city that's always possible
thank you
okay uh senator we're going to move on
to our next speaker
do you plan on uh staying on the line
with us and you have another uh i have
to add up actually to concord i have a
huge hearing and energy on a number of
bills today so i've got to get prepared
for that
thank you so much for testifying
at this point move on to
the hma uh what al johnson
thank you
uh
thank you mr chairman uh i signed up to
speak uh just in case uh i felt it was
necessary but at this point i i don't
think that it is so i'll
yield my time to the next speaker
okay thank you
uh
next we have uh
fred t-bone it's uh it's fred are you uh
mr t-bone are you online with us
okay um
members of the house committee and the
municipal
municipal and county government my name
is fred t boom
and i'm a former ultimate at large
and a resident in nashua and i was one
of the originators of the
city spending capital referendum
citizens petition referendum back in
which passed with a pretty good majority
and uh
survived a number of recall attempts by
teachers
unions effective
july 5 2011
data came up earlier
the new hampshire legislature enacted
authority for cities and towns
to adapt
adopt a spending cap or tax cap
subject to a number of conditions
and included a provision to override the
cap
with the super majority vote
and the left adopted the communities
that adopted this camp
but the super majority vote was
in the case of nashua of course it's a
two-thirds vote of the altman and in
towns of course it's the uh
it's the legislature just like in cities
now prior to year 2011
seven cities
had adopted the tax cap or spending cap
each cap
had passed legal scrutiny
prior to adoption
into their respective charges and had to
be adopted into a charter according to
49b
through a review of the secretary of
state
the attorney general and the department
of reference administration each of
these departments had to
rule on the
uh proposed
spending a tax cap before it could be
adopted and in every case if there was a
negative vote then it could not be
adopted
so all those that were adopted passed
legal scrutiny by these three
departments
now there was also a case board in
manchester in 2010
by various labor unions
to try to
declare spending and tax caps in new
hampshire illegal
and that got struck down
and
that lawsuit did not succeed
now the new hampshire legislature then
passed the spending of tax cap
legislation 2011
specifically a response to that
manchester court case
and because there had been these fire
adapted caps
and caps could not necessarily predict
what the legislature would come up with
and had some inconsistencies of course
you know you can't predict
back in 1993 what people are going to
decide in 2011 as an example
so the legislature clearly intended to
grandfather
previously enacted tax or spending caps
of any kind
and the copy has a language of
rsa49b132a which is the
subject of the current amendment
the new hampshire supreme court
[Music]
in year 2019 that's the case that
denmark and i brought
in a split treated to this vision very
rare in the hampshire was treated to
split the decision
ruled
that the last sentence
of rsa
49b32a
invalidates
his grandfather provision
thereby terminating
at the decision
the national cap
and thereby also threatening all
the validity of all tax and spending
caps adopted prior to 2011.
now i should mention because i heard a
comment earlier
there were two issues before the supreme
court one
is exclusion the same as an override
and nasa has an exclusion
which has always been interpreted as an
override the supreme court said the word
exclusion the word override are not the
same thing and so they said that's not
valid
but then the issue came up
whether nasa's
spending cap was grandfathered so i
would say 49b 132a
and then they ruled and i've made this
decision i'll tell you i've read it 100
times
if you look at page
lines six
and seven
of your amendment the first page
you see the sentence is struck out
that is a sentence starting with without
regard whether such entities
or an accident were archived by law
and the tango establishment taken they
found that
to
negate the grandfather clause
i said i read it a hundred times
i got a decision a thousand times
and i'm puzzled by the decision it's a
three-to-two decision
the
two
against were totally opposed to that
decision but nevertheless if people make
a decision you can't further appeal any
further at the end of the
street as far as natural law goes
so
the amended
sb 52 before you
correct his inequity
by striking the last sentence
apart
49b132a that's line six and seven of the
sb 52 text that i just mentioned
and this revalidates
all spending and text gaps
that were legally adopted
prior to 2011 but have some minor
differences of current law such as in
particular in case of nashua
the issue is it's an exclusion the same
as an override i mean you can nitpick
yourself out to death
the fact is
nash is a grandfather so even if you
argue about whether exclusion or an
override is the same thing or not the
same thing
nash's grandfather if you strike that
first sentence that sentence at line six
and seven
that takes away the objection of the
supreme court
and that's his grandfather and any this
is the most important part there are
seven i said six the seven caps
all of them have some variations
with the two numbers
mr
uh
first of all we thank you for your long
time service to your community but can i
ask you to try to wrap in the next few
minutes yes i'm in the last paragraph
show thank you
i encourage you to vote
in favor of the amended sb52
and eliminate the gross inequity
committed by the national supreme court
when it rejected the 322 vote the clear
intent
of the legislature
to grandfather
tax on spending caps of any kind and
that's a language
and i'll say 49b 13 too
thank you
next uh is your
question uh representative for your
question
yes mr chair thank you for for taking
allowing me and asked mister tebow can
you tell me what percentage
is needed to pass a spending cap
in uh nashua what percentage of the vote
is it simple majority or is it
two-thirds or is it
or what is it two-thirds vote
of the
all of the board of elements it takes
ten votes
the the members of the public don't vote
on it
members of the public don't vote on any
of the then the legislators
thank you
thank you uh next uh
next uh speaker we have is uh dan
where are we already
hey are you with us
mr chair i was i'm trying to look for
mr moriarty and i don't see him by by
name there are two people who are
calling in
um
and i don't see it by any other title i
see um
i have the mayor donchess on there but i
don't see mr moriarty we have uh the
arnold kentwombley with this
yes give me just a second
and the honorable mr twambley should be
good to go
i need to unview
i think i unmuted do you hear me yes
dude you sound great uh go ahead and
continue
good good morning representatives
i'm timothy twombly from wad 7 in nashua
i'm speaking in favor of sb 52
during my six years as a state
representative
and it was confirmed this morning that
it was in 2011 that we voted for this
new legislation
i voted in support of that legislation
relating to spending caps and tax caps
because of a problem that manchester was
having
testimony at that time stated that
cities and towns with existing tax or
spending caps would not be affected by
the new legislation
and those existing caps would remain in
force
and that's why i was willing to support
it to help out the city of
nashua however recently the supreme
court has ruled differently on this
matter for nashua
i support this legislation as it
resolves the issue of
vague
or inconsistent wording encloses
loopholes in the current law
and as we've heard this morning it all
relates to exclusions
and overrides
so i thank you very very much for
listening to me
yes a question from representative tripp
thank you mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question
uh
this all seems to revolve around
override versus exclusion
do you know
what the difference is
i do not i do not know all i know is the
supreme court thinks there's a
difference
[Music]
okay any other thank you very much
you're welcome
see you thank you uh
mr twombly um i think i recognize your
voice and uh
it's quick to hear from you uh next we
have uh dan moriarty if he's uh if he's
here uh representative matthew or did he
log on yet
i unfortunately mr chair i still cannot
find mr moriarty
unless
i i would only ask and i i still can't
find if he's calling in on some in some
other by some other title uh but i don't
see him
mr moriarty did you if you're listening
did you call in on the telephone if you
did please speak up
i believe you have to do a was it a star
six can i mute yourself
or if he could raise his hand if he's a
number ending seven nine nine or six
seven eight those are the two phone
numbers that we see listed
okay in the meantime let's uh let's
recognize uh mayo donchez
uh
maya you've uh
with all the respect you've asked for a
ten minute speaking period i'd like to
ask you to try to cut that in half and
stay uh five minutes or less
um okay mr chair can you hear me yeah
and you sound fine please
all right well i didn't know that i'd
asked for 10 minutes so i apologize for
that yes i could definitely speak in
less than 10 minutes
first of all i wanted to and i thank you
for of course hearing us mr chair and
members of the committee
i wanted to correct a couple of the
things that have been said so far first
in terms of
representative porter's question
and a charter amendment
does not need a two-thirds majority of
the population it requires a simple
majority meaning a one-vote margin is
enough to pass a charter amendment
um
number two uh the people are not
outraged by what you know whatever the
the senator my friend senator avarden
uh suggested that the people are
outraged the people are not outraged
those who have run based on the platform
you've heard
including my friend senator avard and
my friend fred tebum they've run for the
board of aldermen they lost based on
this platform
is there someone else speaking
if you're not uh speaking please uh put
yourself on
mute ahead mayor
i think maybe put yourself on mute i
think
there you go right so those who have run
based on this platform have have all
lost actually so the people are not
outraged but i would ask
that you asked the citizens of that you
allow the citizens of nashua to resolve
this whole thing i mean this is a local
issue
uh the reason that this is before the
legislature is that the
the people do not support particularly
the efforts that are being made here and
that's why
instead of presenting this to the city
they're kind of they're coming to the
legislature
now the
suggestion that the city budget is out
of control or something that i mean that
is just not correct
the last five years the budget has gone
up on average of less than three percent
the
uh right now
the biggest
problem we're facing and why at the tax
cap or a budget or tax cap like this can
become a problem
is that with all due respect mr chair
the state of new hampshire is hitting us
slamming us right now with
a lot of increased costs and reduced
revenues
specifically pension bill up 4.4 million
dollars
unrelated if you talk with a pension
system it has nothing to do with city
wages it had to do with the reduction in
the assumed rate of return by the
pension system four point four million
dollars that's a two per that's a two
percent tax increase right there
number two
uh the amount under the the formula of
the department of education the
amount for reimbursement of free and
reduced lunch kids is going to go down
over 2 million dollars
that is an artificial reduction
we do not have less free and reduced
lunch kids than we did before in fact we
have more
but the reason
is that the federal government made
lunches free during the pandemic
so the paperwork which is quite
extensive that is necessary to qualify
families for free and reduced lunch
there's no real incentive for families
to fill this out anymore
they're busy they have jobs you know
they
and it's an easy thing to just you know
put to the back burner
so less families have qualified
even though more families and these are
low income people they're
lower income people they're not doing
well during the pandemic
so here is a reduction of state aid of
over 2 million dollars
now
it is so what the sponsors here are
suggesting is that
somehow the when the city is
put under that kind of pressure by the
state of new hampshire and i you know
i'm not holding any individual
legislators you know responsible there's
a lot of things going on
uh when the city when the state is
putting
nashua and other communities under that
kind of pressure to at the same time be
enacting legislation suggesting that
somehow nashua is
budget and taxes are out of control i
mean
were it were it not for what the state
is doing to us right now our tax rate
would be flat or down based on the
budget that i have proposed but it's
going to be going up three or four
percent because we've got to deal with
these issues
that the state is
hitting us with
our city hall budget is down 2.7 percent
this year
our public works budget is down 1.9
percent our public library budget is
down 1.9 percent but taxes are going to
go up
because we have to
find that four million dollars for
increased pension costs we have to
somehow replace
the
uh reduction in revenue from the free
and reduced lunch uh formula
so
look you know i just ask that you just
let the citizens of nashville resolve
this if spending is out of control they
will
take care of it
and the people who advance this agenda
or saying these things will
get elected
so
you know each city and town and i know
you're from some people are from cities
and some are from towns but each city
has its own system here and there are a
lot of tax caps and
and budget caps and
those are all enacted at the local level
the state is not imposing these things
on cities and towns because i think most
legislators understand the
difficulties that cities and towns are
having
with the pandemic and with some of the
problems at the state level that impact
us locally so
i would ask that you allow the citizens
of nashua the government of nashua
if
this is a problem put it
put it you know correct it locally
and that's uh what i so i would ask you
mr chairman to
recommend an expedient to legislate
thank you mayor uh i'm not sure how
demanding is scheduled this morning but
it's time to take a question or two yeah
yeah of course
representative andrew question for the
mayor
thank you mr chair thank you mayor for
taking my question
thank you for
highlighting the referendum
how it went
in nashua in terms of uh spending cap
wasn't there a referendum that went down
to
um
in regards to cap spending cap a few
years ago
and uh also
there was a referendum that the voters
wanted to
support the city to make the appropriate
when we had the new high schools and all
that
at that time wasn't there a referendum
that the overwhelming majority
of citizens
supported
uh the project in the spending
well there have been various votes and
uh at various times another thing that i
wanted to i point out is that all the
budgets have passed with us the
so-called super majority i mean
uh the budgets have been passing with
more than 10 votes
in fact usually 12 13 14 15. um
so super majority is already passing
these budgets um
and the budgets are reasonable and and
rational um
one other correction that i wanted to
give you is that the question was asked
and i forget by whom
as to when the nashua city charter was
enacted and the answer was
1993. no
the city charter was enacted
well over 100 years ago
now the
the spending cap that uh you
[Music]
that's at issue here
was
adopted by a very narrow majority
actually in 1993
following uh some problems a revaluation
and some other things but
uh those are the actual correct years
good morning i wanted to speak on senate
bill 102 not not this bill thank you mr
chairman okay please hold on we'll get
to that shortly uh okay thank you you
have uh miss jennifer wolfe who has her
hand raised
i have mr chair i've asked miss jennifer
wolfe to unmute
if you could unmute then
we can hear you speak
okay it looks like
maybe she dropped up
all right another uh representative
tripp has a question for the mayor
thank you mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question
down just
uh
but i just called in to
let you know that dan moriarty is muted
um i just called so that
you could un unmute him he's dialed in
on his phone
okay thank you this is christina
no that was jennifer wolfe mr chair um
all right
well uh
mr morgan here uh
we'll get to you next right now
representative tripp has before
oh
it seems that uh if i can resume it
seems that the
crux of this problem is that there was a
difference between exclusion versus
override
do you know what the difference between
those two words are
yes
um
the
the nashville city charter adopts a very
or had you know had in it a very um
complicated way to try to
uh
deal with a situation where
the proposed spending might be over the
spending cap
and it did not and it does not conform
with state law so
the
rather than a simple override you know
we vote to override there was this thing
where there's this provision where you
vote to ex where there's a vote to
exclude from the camp or from the
consideration portions of the city
debt service
and
up to the full amount of the city's debt
service i you know so it
it was a very weird provision now
it is a very weird provision now the um
in terms of the way this
was arose i mean the city didn't contest
you know didn't take this thing to court
um mr t boom and mr moriarty brought
this to court
they sued the city the city simply
you know uh on a very technical issue
the city simply reject you know
simply uh
just you know disagreed with them on the
technical issue that they raised
and the court ruled on its own volition
that this that this complicated
procedure did not conform with state law
and the supreme court affirmed it so
this is not this you know this is not
something the city try you know went to
court to try to put this aside
um
uh this was done by the the proponents
that are advocating for this bill
so you know i i'm still asking that you
just resol let this local citizens
resolve this um
people who have advanced this locally
have gotten
you know the idea that things are out of
control and everything have gotten
nowhere
they they can't get elected and because
the people think that the city is acting
responsibly
well thank you mayor i think that's the
last question we have for you
at this point we're going to move on to
uh
dan moriarty thank you mr chair
well
mr chair i i see i see one listed as
call-in user and one number ending in
262 and i've asked the number ending 262
to unmute and we'll take our shot that
that is mr moriarty
okay
let's see
we know if mitch wolf wants to speak on
her own behalf or she just can't let us
know about mr yard
oh here we go 262 is unmuted now
go ahead we
hello my my name is actually jennifer
wolf and i'm just letting you know that
dan is
muted um dr moriarty is muted so if you
could just
i didn't hear what you said but his um
his number ends and let me look
hear me can you hear me can you hear me
[Music]
finally thank you very much uh
a couple things first the uh the
national lawsuit
that i brought up
was a result of
the alderman not respecting
the spending cap as written
it was not a lawsuit that was brought up
in
opposition to it so
mayor donches sort of that was his
portrayal but
the aldermen were not respecting
the spending cap and that's why we have
this legislation
because it one of the things that it
does
is it
closes some of the loopholes that the
aldermen of nashua
were taking advantage of
one thing i'd like to point out is that
although
sb 52
the genesis of it may have been
to fix just the nashua spending cap
in the process especially through
discussions with the senate attorney
we discovered that all spending caps in
new hampshire are at risk because of
similar
problems so
for instance to address specifically
what mayor don just said is that this
bank nashville's spending cap is not
complaint with the law
well nashua spending cap actually
predates the law
and that's the problem there are several
spending caps where the people
passed
a referendum and establish a spending
cap and use their own language as best
they knew at the time
and then there were subsequent
lawsuits
and as a result of the subsequent
lawsuits the legislature
responded to the lawsuits in order to
reinforce existing spending caps so the
legislature has already attempted to
reinforce the national spending cap
which predated the law
and and used the term exclusion
and
override differently
the legislature at the time meant those
two words to mean the same thing just as
nashua meant those words to mean the
same thing but when you get in the court
of law sometimes people can argue one
way or another and the judges can rule
differently and that's the case here
so what we found in trying to clarify
the issue of
of exclusion versus
versus override
we found that all spanning caps are at
risk and so this sp52 does two things
the first thing it does is it fixes
the grandfather clause the legislature
knew that they can't go through and just
fix every word of every charter it's
just it's just ridiculous to even think
that
expect them to do that so they put a
grandfather clause in that was very
clear
and this and that got
hung up in court and so this does one
thing it fixes that grandfather clause
and the second thing it does is it
tries to fix the problem with exclusion
versus override so now i want to reject
another thing which mayor donches sort
of portrayed differently than i would
the nashua spending cap as written is
actually very simple it's not a
complicated thing very simple it's
actually only two sentences believe it
or not
one sentence actually
specifies the override very simple
calculation
and then the next section heading is
titled exceptions to the spending cap
the title in the charter
very explicitly says that this is how
you ex exceptions to the spending cap
you can tell from the title that its
intent is as an exclusion as a weight as
a relief valve
they could have said relief valves to
the spending cabin and the courts would
have liked that word better
that's in there where they talk about
how to exclude things
so
so let me read quickly my prepared
statement the original version of the
sb52 was a direct response to the
supreme court and it had a lot of stuff
and it was confusing so
after its introduction with a senate
after its introduction
the senate attorney scrutinized the
language
and offered some comments so the current
version of sb52 is much simpler and
incorporates the input from many parties
excluding those and downs and existing
caps now this is from listening into all
these discussion
it sounds like you know sb 52 and is
written and we don't know it's all messy
and complicated it's actually not
there's been a lot of thought that's
gone since it was introducted into the
senate
and
there's been a lot of
senator gray he was fastidious with us
and making us he was cracking the whip
and said you guys have got to get this
straight
and so we worked with the senate
attorney we sent it out all to the other
cities that might be possibly be
affected
and got inputs back so this has gone
through a lot of edits a lot of
revisions and so this version is much
simpler it's not perfect
i'm not saying it's perfect and it's not
all-encompassing so
if if you're an opponent to spending
caps you could still take take them to
court if you wanted to in the future but
at least this version fixes the stuff
that we know are a problem
and what it does is it puts the the
it does not create any new restrictions
that's another thing that some people
may
may accidentally believe so senate
senate bill 52 does not create any new
restrictions
if you don't already have a spending cap
it doesn't affect you in fact there's a
question earlier somebody asked about
what's the super majority of who is the
super majority of the people or super
majority of elected officials
if you if
you only have a spending cap if you have
elected officials is the way the state
law is written
so this when it talks about requiring a
super majority it's only in the context
of
if you already have a spending cap in on
the books
if you don't already have a spinning cap
on the books then this sp52 doesn't even
affect you
so it does not create new restrictions
it simply provides rigor to the existing
statutes so thank you for
your patience
i apologize
about the uh
the muting issue
i guess it's star six
uh thank you very much
thank you uh mr
uh representative steve if you have a
question for uh
[Music]
my apologies mr chair
um it's a question in general based on
several of the the folks who have
testified
okay go ahead
um
thank you uh
we heard a lot of um
testimony early on about the purest form
of democracy
and now we're hearing about people not
trusting the aldermen
in this particular city to do the right
thing
it isn't throwing them out and electing
a new board of aldermen the purest form
of democracy
that's one question
my second comment is that this committee
sees
many bills that come before for it
that try to address specific issues in
specific towns or cities
and we have always made it a practice to
try to
try to avoid using state legislation to
solve a local problem
thank you
absolutely i can answer both of those
the second one i'll answer first and
that that issue of it being appearing as
a fix for nashua was one of the things
that senator gray was very keen on he
said we don't want to do that
and
the answer lies in the 2011
legislature
so nashua had already
crafted a spending cap and it was fine
all by itself
it was simple spending cap and a simple
exception to the spending cap you know
and then it was after the fact that
other cities manchester had a spending
cap and people in manchester
took manchester to court
people who didn't like the spending cap
in manchester went to court and said
this is wrong and then the legislature
tried to fix manchester's problem and in
the process of the legislature trying to
fix manchester's problem they they broke
nash with a spending cap
so
and then you then if you look statewide
at other spending caps they all have
their own
unique
verbiage but the legislature
so what we have here is the legislature
needs to fix the problem it created
that's what we need to do
so
it's not the legislature fixing nashua's
problem it's the legislature fixing a
problem that it created trying to solve
manchester's problem and broke nashua's
problem
so then back to the period purest form
of democracy
yes indeed uh you could vote them out
and in fact right now the board of
aldermen frankly you know what's the
effect of this fb-52 is going to be very
little in the near future because
on the board of all them you've got 15
aldermen that all like-minded uh
and so they're gonna they're gonna have
their super their
nashua board of aldermen is gonna have
no problem whatsoever having a super
majority for the near future
but that's the way it works out but the
essence of
when things are close
when you have a it's not 90 10 liberal
conservative in nashua it's only 51.49
so the whole purpose of having super
majorities at all and having a spending
cap and the people who wrote the laws at
the state level the spending cap
but they just wanted to have a
a level a higher level a threshold a
higher threshold so when it's a close
call in the electorate when the people
of nashua are 50 50 or the people in
manchester 48 52 or the people in these
cities it's it's a it's just a majority
we recognize that in those cases to have
something that's a major significance
that a super majority is a good way to
go and hence the spending caps require
super majority to override
our next question comes from
alicia houston who would you like to
direct
your question to
can you hear hear me
yes you can
can you hear me
yes we can go right now okay um sorry so
my uh my hand raised was actually to
give um a testimony and support
okay
so
i don't actually have any questions for
mr moriarty if that's okay
okay uh should we have anyone record in
support is there anything another
comment you'd like to make
um yeah so
uh but do you want to get to questions
for mr moriarty should there be any
uh no
oh go ahead
okay perfect
so i want to start by saying thank you
to uh to all of your representatives for
the opportunity to speak um i
wanted to speak today in support of
senate bill 52
i am a lifelong new hampshire resident
and a mother of two children and at this
time we have an ideology in many cities
and towns there is a limitless amount of
funds available to continue growing a
budget outside
of their
previously set budgets now as a nashua
resident and a mother of two district
children the excuse of free or reduced
hot lunch is a fallacy the true issue in
these regards for clarification as
understood by teachers is that the free
or reduced hot lunch forms are sent
home many times with the mandate of
remote
learning over a year it was merely
impossible
as a feat given that many of our
district children in those lower income
locations did not have access to
technology and still remain without
access that fell on the responsibility
of the district who failed to provide
many with those necessary accesses mayor
manchester's incorrect with regards to
to that additionally this further proves
the need to hold our cities and towns
accountable
to remove the idea that money is
limitless and that budgets mean nothing
i encourage you all to view this as a
bigger picture taking nashua aside many
many new hampshire residents and cities
and towns
face the same struggles and challenges
although budgets are previously set and
are encouraged to be followed i
encourage you all to view the big
picture
many new hampshire residents in their
respective cities and towns fall into
the same predicament we are in here in
nashua this is a universal problem not
specific to nashua
this is a matter of accountability this
is helping the new hampshire residents
this is a means for us as citizens and
voters to have a means to hold our
municipalities accountable
in many areas throughout new hampshire
voters and taxpayers are at risk to have
local spending caps exceed those budgets
that were previously set without our
ability as citizens taxpayers and voters
throughout many cities and towns we are
unable to hold our cities accountable i
beg you to support senate bill 52
not just for nashua but for all of our
municipalities and our elected officials
who fail to realize that once you have
committed to a budget that is a
commitment you are making to your
constituents
thank you
my uh my well-trained ears tell me that
you have some written testimony
from
geo and i will send it to you guys i
wasn't originally going to testify uh i
was going to send you guys an email um
and then children um and dogs so i
apologize i will make sure that i send
that over to you guys
it helps us administer everybody you can
send that to us by email thank you
absolutely i will get that taken care of
okay i think that's our last speaker um
and
we're going to close the hearing on
senate bill 52 and move forward
[Music]
before we open the hearing on our next
bill which will be
central 87 i do want to
welcome some substitutes
that have uh courageously volunteered to
help us
extend uh representatives video and
grassy
uh i'm here uh volunteering this time to
keep our committee full and uh
all right we're going to now open the
hearing on senate bill 87 i'm sorry
i just wanted to ask if you could kindly
read the number of support and oppose on
this bill that we just heard sure uh
those who
signed in on the bill 24 were in support
36 for an opposition one was neutral
we have senate bill 87
which is an army omnibus
bill relative to municipal finance
and i believe we have uh senator
burnsell
indoor senator carson introduced bill
[Music]
to chair i i do see senator carson who
should be able to speak
okay let me welcome senator carson the
floor is yours
um good morning mr chairman and good
morning members of the house
municipal um committee uh for the record
my name is sharon carson and i have the
pleasure of representing senate district
14 comprising the towns of london derry
hudson and auburn and i have um for your
consideration today house bill 87 and
your
chair is completely correct that this is
an omnibus bill
um
mr chairman i am prepared to speak on my
part of the bill
and not on the other parts of the bill
perhaps there are folks who would like
to speak to the first section of the
bill for
senator
birdsall
is there anybody online that would like
to uh take up
part one of the bill
mr chair i don't see senator birdsell
so far
and it appears from our list that uh the
senator birdsell did sign up to speak
for part one but i don't recognize
anybody else specifically for part one
um but i do see senator bradley's hand
up
okay
and senator bradley can you speak to
part one are you gonna speak on part
three
uh good morning mr chairman part three
only thank you
okay well senator carson why don't we
move forward with uh part two and then
hopefully senator barroso will join us
uh during
during the uh hearing
thank you thank you very much mr
chairman um the second part of the
omnibus bill would amend current statute
to enable a municipality to charge a fee
for any financial remittance issued to
the municipality municipality excuse me
that is returned as uncollectible
current law rsa 80 colon 56 only provide
the ability for municipalities to charge
a fee for checks returned to the city or
town is uncollectible no other form of
financial remittance is identified in
the current statute
with more and more services by cities
and towns being conducted through online
transactions payments for services
are being made by methods other than
paper checks
financial transactions can be done by
eight ch transactions
electronic fund transfers or efts
credit card payment and other electronic
means despite the convenience of the
electronic payments they are not
foolproof
and can be returned as uncollectible in
the same manner that a check can
many municipalities have learned this
during the past year as we transitioned
to more online services and transactions
as a result of of the covet issues
and um
at this point um
the request is to amend to broaden the
means of
payment municipalities received to
enable us to collect a fee for any form
of financial payment
and at that point
mr chairman i will conclude my testimony
i know that
there are folks from the municipal
association
who will be uh testifying and they will
be able to answer your questions much
better than i can so i will thank you mr
chairman and the committee for your time
this morning
thank you very much thank you senator i
appreciate the time uh you sent it are
there any questions for senator carlson
yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
carson for taking my question my
question um
pertains to line nine
where the language in the text says that
the fee together with other fees
shall be for the use of the city or town
the use of the city or town is very
non-specific
so i just wanted to verify therefore
that it would be up to the discretion of
the city or town as to what fund and
where that money would would be
would go and be utilized
thank you very much for your question
representative it is my understanding
yes that once the fee is collected it is
um up to the town to decide where that
money is to go but again there are folks
from the municipal association will be
able to testify and will be able to give
you a more accurate answer
thank you
thank you thank you any other questions
for senator carson
seeing none
we'll we'll hear from uh
dave karen uh from the town of derry
the town manager
welcome welcome mr karen
uh good morning mr chair how are you
good
good thanks for the opportunity to
provide comment on part one
uh this section was
uh submitted into legislation by senator
birdsall on our behalf
and
we believe the passage of this part of
the bill
would assist our time with meeting its
economic development goals to the
benefit
of our residents and the residents of
the state of new hampshire you know the
town a few years ago was approached by
the department of environmental services
to participate in the southern new
hampshire regional water interconnection
project
which is an
ambitious project which now provides
water generated by the manchester water
to communities south and east of derry
and derry's uh pre-existing robust water
system infrastructure
is now also being used to convey water
from manchester point south
you know as we all know state fiscal
policy requires
towns and cities to rely upon its
property tax base to fund a majority of
local services with this in mind
our town council is initially
somewhat apprehensive to share
one of our critical economic development
our water system with the region
but the council also wanted to be good
neighbors and help ensure that an ample
supply of clean quality water was
available to the region
as the into municipal agreement
governing this partnership was developed
the town looked for opportunities that
the town would not be adversely impacted
economically by its participation
during these discussions the council
became comfortable with this partnership
as began to identify other economic
development tools which may become
available through the availability of
wheeling revenues
rsa 38 which is the state law governing
water systems currently restricts all
revenues to the water fund
as the statute never contemplated such a
project as this and its potential impact
upon regional economic development
passage of this bill will allow the town
to further expand its economic
opportunities by investing in various
initiatives whether it be the extension
of municipal soared to areas of the town
currently not serviced
or by participation
in the various economic development
activities as authorized under the
industrial land facilities statute as
well as the municipal economic
development and revitalization district
statute
of course our first obligation is
priority we will continue to guarantee
that our water system
has the resources necessary to perform
under this intermissible agreement and
to protect our system's integrity
it is envisioned any excess funds would
then be invested into the town's
economic development opportunities
this plan of action benefits both our
water customers and the dairy property
taxpayers who have shared the town's
bond rating and capacity as well as
other resources over the years to assist
with the water system's growth
reliability and financial strength
again i thank you for the opportunity to
offer comment on senate bill 87 part one
and i urge the committee to support this
initiative in recognition of the spirit
of cooperation extended by the dairytown
council to the southern new hampshire
regional water interconnection project
thank you thank you mr pam before we
take questions for you uh
just a point of
interest in the public can you help if
you look at the bill
on page one line
thirteen
it talks about
funds collected from the collection of
water wheeling charges can you explain
to the public what a water wheeling
charge
sure walling reading
water wheeling charges is a cost which
is
added on to the cost of the water from
manchester water works
to
communities south of us and it's then
is
given to the town of dairy
in the intermissive agreement the charge
is a dollar per 100 cubic feet
and again those funds are
are used currently to pay for our costs
our electrical costs our maintenance
costs our pump maintenance costs and and
water uh conveyance systems uh to ensure
that the flow of water to communities
south of us so it's a it's an add-on to
the to the uh bill which is uh levied by
the manchester waterworks the community
south of derry
thank you uh representative
question for the the
town manager gary
yes i i do mr chair i'm not sure if he
can answer it but i'm hoping he will
because it's just something that's
bothering me thank you um for taking my
testimony
i'm i want to be assured
okay i'm going to preface this here
where i live my water bill is quite high
um
i want to be assured
that if this
passes
people who live in districts unlike
yours that just have their own water
system
won't be able to use my water fees to
buy
street lights
am i is that
i want to make sure that this only
relates to
people who are part of an inter
municipal agreement and not everybody's
water and sewer systems all over the
state can you give me that assurance
okay thank you uh for your question uh
uh two things one is that
uh
we have an obligation first to make sure
that our water system is robust
second uh when we were working with
senator birds on this bill
uh all felt comfortable putting guard
rails around the use of excess revenues
therefore we've included uh language in
the proposed bill which would limit that
to economic development uh activities
uh within the the town of derry and
regarding
regarding fees it should be noted that
our water fees are and it's really
predicated on on our water fees
are in the lower uh lower of the 30th
percentile in the state so we have a
very robust water system our water fees
are low so
this wheeling charge is already in place
it's just a just a matter now of
requesting legislative approval to
expand the use of proportional proceeds
for economic development purposes in
dairy i hope i answered your question
can i have a follow-up just follow-up
you sort of did but not really i live in
hillsboro we're not part of an
intermunicipal
compact agreement
if this
clause passes
will my water department be able to use
the fees and revenue that it has for
buying street lights
okay i understand thank you no they will
not and you know when again we crafted
this bill
uh we were really concerned about the
world of unintended consequences
therefore if you look at the bill it is
an arrow the stat the stat the statue in
front of you but it's limited to
communities which have a charter under
49 i think it's d32a i can't recall
frankly
but there's only two uh units of
government which which has that uh has
that form of government and that is the
towns of
derry and durham
and i've spoken with the town manager of
durham to explain what we're doing he
was comfortable with our approach and
confirmed or not impact uh his operation
so that's why we put the additional guy
rails around this legislation thank you
very much that does answer my question
and also uh
quoting
rsa it's rsa 49b31
okay thank you
uh any other questions
yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question mr karen
i was curious to understand um with
under part 1 on line 17
how the
um was arrived at
so my understanding um
is that
no more than 50 percent of the water
wheeling charges
um
shall be used for other purposes
cited here in
the bill
um
other than the um
the maintenance and upkeep of the water
system
so
i'm just curious to understand
um where the 50 came from
yeah thank you uh for the question
representative there's there's no real
magic formula to that number uh when we
first approached senator birdsall about
this and spoke with the
senate legislative services they felt it
was appropriate
uh to ensure that a a minimum amount of
funds stayed in the water fund and so
all felt comfortable with no more than
50 percent being transferred out of the
waterfront for economic development
purposes
thank you thank you
thank you mr karen
next we have senator bradley to speak to
part three
good morning mr chair how are you
good good lisa
please go right ahead you have the floor
okay thank you very much um
i was asked by the town of sandwich to
submit this legislation
that would allow more flexibility
for a lease purchase agreement
they worked with the municipal
association
this bill
was on the docket a year ago and it got
caught up in the covid um
situation where a lot of things got
tabled
so i'm bringing it back again and as
senator carson said
i'm sure somebody from the municipal
association can better answer
uh your questions the other thing i
would add
we have the nhma on right after you at
that speed okay the um i don't know if
you want to take more testimony on the
first section because senator burnsville
um is not
able to attend but our uh policy
director grant bossie is on the call
and you can um go to him for senator
birzel's testimony on part one
who is that
uh grant bossie
okay
thank you thank you senator i'm i'm not
sure how long you can stay with us but
i don't see any questions for you okay
great i see one question
can you take the question
yep thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator bradley for taking my question
with regard to part three i was curious
to understand
um the rationale for striking out lines
21 and 22.
um you know
uh representative best for you to ask um
the municipal association this is the
way the town of sandwich proposed it to
me
um
in the particular
particularities of how they conduct
their town meeting and that's what they
requested
thank you senator i appreciate your time
today and uh next up we'll talk to
cordell johnson nhma
thank you mr chairman um
cordell johnson representing new
hampshire municipal association
and i actually uh am testifying in
support of all three parts of the bill
uh and i know we're sort of jumping
around a little bit
um but i think i can do it pretty
quickly part one uh simply uh we support
it um it's really uh as dave karen
indicated it's really limited at this
point to the town of derry and it only
affects a town that would be part of an
inter-municipal agreement so i don't
really have anything more to say on part
one just to register our support for it
um part two i think is pretty
self-explanatory and i know you have a
letter from um
from the uh town administrator for the
town of auburn
uh and that is just bringing
that statute into the uh
into the 21st century to allow
uh a municipality to collect
uh a charge on unpaid remittances that
are that are made electronically
uh as opposed to the current statute
which
only allows them for um
those that are that are paid by check
and uh obviously
there's a lot more electronic fund uh
uh payments these days
and then on part three which uh may
require a little more explanation but i
i do believe there is also someone
from the town of sandwich who has signed
up to testify christopher bolt
but
basically part three
deals with the use of capital reserve
funds to make payments on a
under a lease purchase agreement
so a town can can establish a capital
reserve fund and those are used uh to
pay for
major purchases like building
construction or buying a large piece of
equipment and various other things
and
the current law
allows the um a capital reserve fund to
be used
to to make payments under a lease
purchase agreement but only under
certain lease purchase agreements
and there are two basic kinds of lease
purchase agreements
one is one that contains a
non-appropriation clause
also known as an escape clause
a non-appropriation clause is a
provision in the agreement that says
if the town fails to appropriate money
in any given year to make that year's
payments under the agreement
then the contract essentially is
terminated it allows the town to get out
of the
uh lease purchase agreement by by not
making the appropriation
and those kinds of lease purchase
agreements
can be approved by a town meeting by a
simple majority vote
the other kind
does not have a non-appropriation clause
it's basically
the the
the town does not have the ability to
get out of it by
uh by failing to make an appropriation
that is treated as long-term debt and it
requires a
vote
voter approval a two-thirds voter
approval at town
meeting so the current statute allows
the use of capital reserve funds to make
payments under a lease purchase
agreement
only if the lease purchase agreement
does not contain a non-appropriation
clause
and has been approved by a two-thirds
vote
and in reviewing this
we couldn't come up with a reason
to have it limited in that way
these purchase agreements are
have become a very popular way of
financing purchases of
especially large pieces of equipment
and it just simply doesn't uh there
doesn't seem to be any reason to
limit the use of capital reserve funds
to only those agreements that that do
not contain a non-appropriation clause
and i'm quite sure i'm pretty sure i
remember that last year we discussed
this with department of revenue
administration they had no
objection to to changing the statute as
this proposes to do
uh and so that's uh that's why we want
to do it it
just takes away
a restriction that can cause problems
for some towns
so that's uh
that's it and i'd be happy to answer
questions and as i said i believe there
is uh i believe chris bolt from the town
of sand which is also
uh signed up to testify
yes uh representative
you get a question
love you mr chair uh yes uh thank you mr
johnson for taking my question my
question is for the part one is there
any
uh idea where the
fund is it just the tax
water tax that people pay that is being
allocated or reallocated or is it are
there any
settlement funds
that also included in this
on part one um
[Music]
i'd
settlement funds i don't think so as i
understand it it's simply the
a portion of the water wheeling charges
which are the charges
that are paid by the uh other
municipalities
uh
by users in the other
uh other municipalities under the um
under the inner municipal agreement so
it's just the payment
payments
the water charge payments themselves
thank you
thank you representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
mr johnston i don't know if you can
answer this
the money that's coming this is it has
to do with part one i just seem to be
a little concerned with it
so
in dairy and i understand what dairy is
doing and i think it's a very good thing
i'm assuming that other communities
send money to derry to allow them
to do this work
the money that they're sending comes
from the users fees for the water from
those cities
so the people who live in
is nashua one of the cities um pay their
water bill for their usage and that
money goes to derry
who then can use
it as outlined in this provision of this
bill is that how it works
that's my understanding a portion of a
portion of that
as as the language indicates
no less than 50 percent has to be paid
specifically for the has to be used
specifically for the water system itself
it's only the excess
um that that can be used for uh other
things that are listed there
and if if i mis-speak on this uh i i
hope dave karen is still on and he can
raise raise his hand and correct me
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
johnston for taking my question
so i just want to be
clear that i understand part three of
this
bill
and so
my understanding is that
the use of the capital reserve funds
as written here can be used for both
um
a lease purchase agreement which does
have an escape clause and also
for those lease purchase agreements
which do not
so it can be used for both types of
lease purchase agreements
that's correct
okay
follow-up follow-up thank you
and um
i had previously asked another um
person with regard to
again on part three line 21 and 22
why those two lines were struck
in am i correct in understanding that
the reason it is struck because um it
ties in
to the um lines 19 and 20 which are also
struck
with regard um saying that the lease
purchase agreement
did not have an escape clause and if
that's going to be eliminated you have
to also strike
lines 21 and 22 to be consistent
yeah yes that's exactly right the
you you would only need that two-thirds
majority vote if if it was a lease
purchase agreement that did not have the
non-appropriation clause so yes if if
you get rid of one it only makes sense
to get rid of two
thank you
thank you uh representative gilman have
a question
thank you mr chair uh and thank you mr
johnson for taking my testimony or my
question
um
this is regards to part one and i'm
sorry to make you jump around but i it
just occurred to me
um
i understand that this uh
that's this part of the bill
only pertains to
places with inter music municipal
agreements
my question is do the such towns and
cities
put those funds into an enterprise fund
for water
as do other small towns like mine
yeah i i think it would i think it would
have to and
uh that presumably would be governed by
the inter-municipal agreement itself
and i and i haven't looked at the
agreement that governs uh the dairy
the dairy situation but i i would
assume that the
the
intermunicipal agreement specifies where
the funds can go
thank you
no further questions for the nhma let's
go to grant bosti
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee my name is grant bosse i'm the
majority policy director over here in
the new hampshire senate uh here on
behalf of senator regina birdsall the
prime sponsor and the author of part one
of this bill do apologize for the
confusion senator birdsall had planned
to attend this uh a doctor's appointment
ran along and then a conflicting senate
hearing um started so she asked me to
pinch hit uh i think you've heard what
you need to hear on this bill
particularly from administrator karen
from the town of derry the senator put
this bill in on behalf of the town of
derry
rsa 38 limits the use of water fees to
uh go back into that system that's good
policy that's good law
but it never anticipated the sort of
inter-municipal agreements that dairy
has with manchester water works and the
communities to its south and east we
think giving derry some flexibility
to use those wheeling charges for
limited purposes outside the water
system itself makes sense
and we ask for
your consideration of that policy change
uh as part of uh senate bill 87 thank
you very much any questions from mr
boston
yes representative porter
thank you mr chairman thank you mr bosse
for taking my question um i'm looking at
section 1 rsa 162 k 6 which is referred
to in the first part of the bill and
there's a list of things that this money
can be used for
section you know roman 3 is specifically
left listed in the bill
and there there's really a lot of things
here
that
acquiring property installing lighting
um air rights
there's all sorts of things in this list
and you know perhaps they have
to do with economic development
but i'm i just can't get over that
somebody is paying their water bill and
that the money that they're paying for
their water is going to go
to buy street lights it just seems wrong
to me so please make me feel better
about that well representative i'd refer
you to line 14 of the bill on page one
um that specifically limits these fees
derived from inter-municipal agreements
so this is money
that is being paid to the town of dairy
for the use of its water infrastructure
to get that water from manchester
through dairy
so this is not um this is not water
being used by the people of dairy
there if dairy is a conduit to get that
water from manchester down to the south
in the east and the policy change that
senator birdsall is asking you to
consider
is that the town of derry
for
being part of this agreement to let the
water flow through it
should be able to have greater
flexibility to use this money
for other purposes
broad economic development purposes but
outside of the traditional limits
of
water systems in rsa 38.
follow mr chair
yes go ahead follow up
but the money that the people of
manchester are sending to derry
comes from the user fees
of the water bills that they're paying
that's where that money is coming from
uh i believe the the wouldn't
necessarily be from manchester it'd be
from the other communities that are
getting their water
i'm using manchester as an example
whoever is sending money to derry
those communities are getting the money
from
the users who are paying for their water
is that accurate yes
okay so someone's paying a water bill
thank you
yes representative for paying their
water bill some of that money goes to
the town of dairy for the use of its
water system
um so yeah they are that's what they are
receiving for that charge
okay uh yes representative
thank you mr chairman and
is this
mr bossy yes okay thank you mr bossy for
taking my question
do you know if um in different cities
that this bill may affect other
excess funds because
this this
this bill here proposes that um no less
than 50 percent of the water wheeling
charges
would be utilized for the maintenance
and upkeep upkeep of the water system
is there excess monies
is 100 of
the money currently being used for
the upkeep and maintenance of the water
infrastructure
i'd defer that to mr karen as he said
this bill was very narrowly crafted so
it would only apply i think to two
communities and the only one currently
in uh one of these agreements is dairy
so i think that question would be better
directed to the town administrator in
derry
mr karen if you're still online can you
handle that question
uh yes can you hear me yes okay okay
great yeah uh
that's correct uh we don't do not
anticipate that
uh 100 of our revenues from this
arrangement
will be needed to maintain our system
however if we have a massive pump
station failure
then obviously that dynamic changes
and
looking back at representative porter's
question
the wheeling charge was to recognize
dairy's sharing of its previous expenses
to build its water system
so looking at it another way
if the if the folks south of
uh dairy wanted to take advantage of the
water produced by the manchester
waterworks
and there was there was no municipal
water system in dairy
those users would be responsible for the
debt service to construct millions of
dollars of pump stations and water lines
through the town of derry
to receive that water so
the wheeling charge was restructured
again preserves it's in recognition of
the past investment made by dairy
taxpayers into its water system which
allowed this project
to come to
fruition thank you mr karen uh
next uh we're going to hear from uh
we alluded to uh the town administrator
from auburn uh william herman
is
uh thank you mr chairman i am and i'll
uh make my comments very brief for the
record my name is william herrmann i'm
the town administrator for the town of
auburn
um
senator carson has sponsored part b of
this legislation at the the request of
the town of auburn and i think she did a
great job as did cordell johnston to
explain
why we believe it's needed it's just
what we view as housekeeping and
catching up with modern times
if i could i think the only other i have
submitted written testimony so i won't
go through that for you
if i could answer one question i believe
the question was asked previously as to
where these fees or monies would go and
largely they will go to pay the bank fee
better charge the municipalities when
somebody issues a payment and it is
returned due to insufficient funds there
are costs that
the municipality or a private business
would incur from
the bank and these fees would cover
those costs so that the taxpayers are
not
covering those expenses
i'd be happy to answer any questions if
you'd like
any questions
thank you mr herman i don't see any
questions i'm going to move on to chris
bolt if he's uh
still with us
good afternoon actually good morning mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is chris bolt
i am a partner at the law firm of
donahue tucker chindela and while we
represent over about a third of the
communities around the state i'm not
here testifying in that capacity for any
client
i
as senator bradley indicated i was
selectmen in sandwich at the time this
bill
was first requested
and it came as a result of
the need for a large piece of equipment
for our highway department
where our capital reserve fund had
some monies in it but not nearly enough
uh we also had other
capital reserve funds for things like
the fire engines things of that nature
that any of you who've
seen these items on your municipal
budgets know those are increasing
greatly
our request started out simply as adding
the the highlighted text
to
rsa 3515 roman 3
including lease purchase agreement
that language was
because dras traditionally stated
that
the funds in a capital reserve amount
could only be used for the last payment
in a lease purchase agreement because
that's when you're actually purchasing
the piece of equipment
uh as
our idea uh took flight
era weighed in
others weighed in and that's why
the language of uh
lines
17 18 19 20 through 22 are stricken
other provisions of the statute
primarily
rsa 33 colon 7 dash c
creates the format for creating a lease
purchase agreement so it doesn't
uh completely get away
from the requirements it's only in this
provision where those double
requirements would be stricken i ask for
your support for uh part three i'm happy
to answer any questions
any questions for our mr bolt
seeing none
for those of you
who are curious for those people who
signed in on this bill uh 10 were in
support
zero were in opposition and zero were
neutral
and that's
gonna conclude our hearing on
senate bill 87
mr pair this is jim representative
majori yes
i just wanted to bring to your attention
that representative mangiapudi seems to
be having some internet uh issues and
has uh fallen off of the panelist screen
and we're doing our best to try to get
her back into the meeting
okay thank you
yes i will thank you
all right the uh the the next and the
last pill we're going to hear today is
two
um
so well uh
up front
we have a lot of people will sign it in
this bill we have
40 that support it one is in opposition
and one is neutral
so let's uh
so on sag bill 102
we have uh the senator perkins polka
with us
[Music]
introduce the bill
i see your representative cody has
rejoined
and i'm looking for senator
thank you
now
mr chair i'm looking for senator
perkins quoca but i can't find the
senator yet
let's go to uh
clifton
below uh
from lebanon
morning mr chairman members of the
municipal and county government
committee
i'm here today to test find support of
part two
of uh senate bill 102.
and
i'll just explain some background i am
testifying on behalf of the city of
lebanon as its assistant mayor uh this
uh bill or part two of this bill enables
a new local option to exempt from local
property taxes but not any state taxes
renewable generation facilities and
electric energy storage systems
why would a immunospot even want to
consider such exemptions the main reason
is that renewable energy and storage are
typically very capital intensive
compared with the capital cost of a
natural gas combined cycle generator
which is the type of generation they
displace on the margin
um so if you levied a tax rate at the
same level based on the capital cost of
the project including if if they were on
similar depreciation schedules or the
replacement costs which are two ways of
valuing real property of the tax burden
on renewable generation and storage per
kilowatt hour would be two to ten times
as much as that for the gas that it
displaces
um in fact
the most common form of renewable energy
a fixed tilt solar system uh faces a
potential property tax burden that's
about seven and a half times that of the
natural gas that it competes with uh per
kilowatt hour
um so that that's that's the important
reason to consider it uh in essence uh
with renewable energy you typically
replace you you invest in capital cost
upfront you know pv system or wind
turbine uh the fuel in those cases
doesn't cost anything uh but the um and
there's a very low operating cost we
um
so most of the value is in the capital
investment whereas what it's competing
against natural gas most of the costs
are in the fuel and the operational cost
which we don't tax plus most of the
generation this might displace on the
margin is actually located out of state
um
i did send testimony to the committee uh
but that was you know just as you were
getting going this morning but that's
available to look at there's some
explanation of that analysis i just gave
you in there um
and i would point it in in real terms
this works out to be very significant
dollars it could mean that um
uh you're you're adding four or five
cents per kilowatt hour to the cost of
renewable uh compared to um
uh uh
uh natural gas that it displaces and it
makes it you know less much less
economic and and potentially not
happening at all
which is generally the case for systems
in the one to five megawatt size uh but
another very specific reason for this
legislation is even though there's
existing options for local property tax
exemptions for certain renewables and
storage systems um they have been
determined by a number of attorneys and
municipalities to only be available to
the owner of the underlying real estate
that is um that's the property owner
that's because there's language in these
other statutes um rsa 72 62 66 70 and 85
let's say the exemptions for persons
owning real property which is equipped
with a solar system or a wind system
so
that if there if the system is owned by
a third party which is common with
non-profits
and for low and moderate income projects
then they're owned by a third party
that's selling to
the you know perhaps the property owner
or or members of the uh
housing development
they're selling them to them
through a purchase power agreement and
in lebanon's case there was a low
moderate income uh project with a
manufactured home resident owned
community called massacoma meadows
and uh that was something that was
supported by the puc
and they assumed that the property tax
would not apply because we adopted an
exemption in lebanon
but because of this interpretation of
the statute it appears as though
you know they should be taxed and we
don't have an ability to exempt that so
um in conclusion i just say that the you
know the language creates a new separate
option for a local exemption it is um
it was sort of introduced over a year
ago but got stuck in the senate because
the synonym
passed it when things shut down because
of the pandemic um
the original language tried to amend the
existing exemptions to allow them to
include third-party own systems but um
the municipal association and the
assessors group uh uh you know um
pointed out that that's a problem
because it sort of changes exemptions
that have already been adopted by
communities so this language was
developed to make it a separate option
that has to be voted on uh locally by
the by the
legislative body of the community to
adopt it so i'll just stop there there's
a lot of information there but it's all
sort of detailed out in
the written the pdf that i sent you with
written testimony which also includes
the excerpts from the other statutes
that that might be relevant to
understanding the context of this
legislation
attention mr chairman and i'm
happy to answer any questions other
questions for mr below
i see none at this time
like to welcome
senator
uh perkins spoken if you'd like to
take the floor go right ahead
thank you so much uh chairman and uh
apologies for joining you a couple
minutes late i was in uh exact session
and senate election law committee so
good morning for the record i'm senator
perkins cuoco from senate district 21
representing the city of portsmouth and
the towns of madbury lead durham
newington new market in newfields
the prime sponsor of part one of sb 102
postponing assessment reviews and
reappraisals of property
i'm bringing this bill on behalf of the
city of portsmouth this lsr would
postpone property tax assessments during
the tax year beginning april 1st 2021.
also any appeal filed for the property
tax year beginning april 1st 2021 will
utilize the 2020 median equalization
ratio as established by the department
of revenue administration for each
municipality for abatement purposes
this lsr will prevent property owners
from having their having to have their
tax assessments occur during an
artificially inflated real estate market
due to covet
assessing property during this bubble
would make it harder and more expensive
for people to stay in their homes during
a time when we've all learned the
importance of home and what that means
it has come to my attention since filing
the bill that the city of portsmouth
will not need to conduct a revaluation
this year but perhaps there are other
communities which may be interested in
this procedure
i know representatives of the dra may be
here today and
i'm open to
any conversation on this bill
mr chairman thank you for the
opportunity to present part one i'm
happy to try to answer any questions and
i also want to mention that um senator
sue prentice is here to present as well
and that um she's a little short on time
if uh if you're able to accommodate
thanks for having me
and that was senator sue
apprentice
thank you uh thank you senator uh the
question for the senate representative
thank you mr chair i first of all i
wanted to state that i'm having some
issues with my uh
internet intermittent so voting
time i might need some help
uh patience
for senator
the
reassessment happens every
five years ten years
if that cycle comes under for portsmouth
this year or did it happen
before
yes ma'am thank you for the question
uh representative the each municipality
is required to conduct a reassessment
when their
combined assessed value
either reaches um 85 of the current
value or i think it's 110 percent so
it's not necessarily every five or ten
years but rather um sort of depends on
what
what happens in the market in terms of
the value of their assessed property so
in portsmouth that tends to happen every
two years um and they've since
determined that this year won't be a
year they need to assess but probably
next year
thank you
next we have uh senator suzanne
apprentice
i believe i am unmuted yes right ahead
good morning and thank you for taking me
i know that we all have uh that we're
all tight on time but as you know we're
we're all moving from meetings to
meetings as we uh narrow down on the end
of the work here in this session so good
morning of representative dolan and
members of the new new hampshire house
municipal and government committee for
the record my name is suzanne prentiss
i'm the state senator from district five
and i just wanted to say a quick hello
to my colleague here and co-resident of
west lebanon new hampshire
representative laurel stavis uh clifton
b former state senator clifton bilo um
gave his testimony and uh
which is
is really the bill that the part of the
bill that i'm here to introduce which is
um section three of senate bill 102
which i am in support of um and as
clifton below stated this has been a
request of the city of lebanon again
where i'm a resident as part of my
district so i just want to share briefly
that lebanon like a growing number of
municipalities in new hampshire have
official commitments and plans to
accelerate our shift to renewable energy
and away from fossil fuels in lebanon
this takes place in form of a master
goal that we've adopted by both our
planning board and city council
and this is relying on
on as much local renewable energy this
is a commitment that we've made as
possible not just as a city government
but a whole city and acting consistent
with the state's climate action plan
with a goal of 80 reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050. our
city council here in lebanon has
unanimously endorsed the paris climate
accord and expressed the intent to act
in support of those goals and even
provide leadership in this regard and
this is part of where senate bill 102
section 3 comes into place there is a
growing realization that the world is in
an accelerating climate crisis including
the us and the action that we need to
take locally as with union again within
our municipalities and extending out to
our entire communities one obstacle
apart in our entire community one
obstacle in new hampshire
to this local progress
on one of these goals is how we apply
the property tax to renewable generation
and storage
more immediately most immediately as uh
clifton below stated limiting this
exemption to only system serving
government will create a very
problematic situation for lebanon and
many other communities we don't want to
tax third party owned pvra serving uh
serving other serving community our
communities property owners and most
importantly are low and moderate income
property owners such as
a project here within the city of
lebanon mascoma meadows cooperative a
resident owned community of manufactured
homes served by a ppa this bill simply
creates
the local option mechanism which we
already have this
but it creates one and extends it to it
creates this and extends it to the third
party's own pv array settings um
although i would like to take your
questions and i'm happy to as best i can
i do rely on
cliff below for most of for most of my
technical assistance but simply here
we're looking to take this local option
that is already in place and extended to
include
our third party owned properties
thank you thank you senator uh
you have time to take a question
i'll do my best if i don't own a less
cliff
thank you
mr thank you uh senator
apprentice um for taking my question so
this will enable
uh
the third party distribute generation
and distribution correct of renewable
energy
it would provide for an exemption
for
third-party
say you know third-party property owners
so here this is a cooperative
not just one resident that owns it
it so it would allow for them
to
have the same tax exemption that
currently i
can have at my home if i were to put it
on my own private piece of property here
in the city
because the city's already adopted that
local option
follow up mr chair yes
thank you so this is for the larger
scale not residential but larger scale
between one megawatt to five megawatt
correct
um
or beyond
i don't think it goes beyond that it
allows
for
it does work behind the meter but what
this is specific to is allowing
local
select boards and city councils to
decide to provide a
tax exemption
for the property whether again a loan or
owned like my house or by this
cooperative so they can take it they're
not assessed on that value
of the solar part of the property
so this
incentivizes
renewables you know moving more towards
renewables because that exemption is in
place
thank you thank you senator uh next
we're going to hear from
nhma doyle johnson and uh mr johnson did
you start off with answering the
question
as you read this legislation you
interpret it as being enabling
legislation
thank you mr chairman
and yes i do interpret it as being
enabling
uh both in part one and in part two
uh and just a clarification um
senator perkins quoca as i heard it was
was testifying on
uh part one of the bill as it was filed
in the senate which would have delayed
uh reappraisals
uh for
a year but but that part
was deleted by the senate so
uh there only are two parts to the bill
now
uh part two is what you heard senator
prentice and cliff below testifying on
part one which i don't think anyone has
addressed yet
has to do with
a slight expansion of rsa 79e
which is the
revitalization tax relief
uh statute and that's the part that i
uh wanted to speak on very briefly and
and uh we were not involved in the
drafting of this uh but but we support
it um
rsa 79e is a statute uh i'm sure some of
you are familiar with it but it allows a
municipality to grant
limited property tax relief to someone
who is engaging in
renovation or
revitalization and originally it was
intended for specifically for historic
structures but it's been expanded a few
times over the years to include some
other things so that if you're
if you're
renovating a structure
that during the period that you're
granted tax relief you're you you do not
have to pay taxes on the increased value
of the
property that results from your efforts
and
senate bill 102
expands that
allows a municipality to expand it to
include
residential property within a defined
residential property revitalization zone
and the idea is to
help
with the uh
revitalization of older properties it
has to be 40 years old or older
and to
help in a limited way to in increase the
supply of housing in the state
and because it is a local option and it
it
would help we think
uh to some to some extent
with improving
um
housing availability
uh we support it i'd be happy to try to
answer questions on that although again
as i say we were not involved in the
drafting of it i suspect there's
probably someone here who could
uh
answer more detailed questions than i
can but i'd be happy to try thank you
thank you mr chair thank you mr johnson
for taking my question how does this
relate to rsa 53 with the pace
district and also the
what is the term or how many years is
this tax
credit or
tax exemption is under
79e and how would change
uh the pace legislation and i have to
admit i am not an expert on that but but
that
uh
this is entirely separate from that this
this is a different form of of property
tax relief
um
the period
under the existing law
the
uh period of property tax relief
is uh
the governing body can grant the relief
for a period of up to five years
however
um
it can
uh
add up to an additional two years for a
project that results in new residential
units
and up to four years
for a project that includes affordable
housing
so i think um
and i guess the question is whether this
would apply when someone is
is uh
creating new residential units and i
think possibly it could
so
to the extent it includes affordable
housing it could be up to nine years
if
representative had a question
uh yes
thank you mr josh
um
on
page two lines uh
six through uh eight
uh
i'm having trouble hearing you but i
think you asked is it is it similar to
another bill that was in the committee
is that the question yes on uh uh
additional dwelling units uh
six through
uh six to eight lines who made on page
two there was there was another bill
that uh the house did pass and i think i
think the senate has actually passed it
now
but i need to check to confirm that
house bill 154
uh
is somewhat similar to senate bill 102
in that they both
provide additional options under rsa 79e
the difference is that house bill 154
is
deals specifically with
um
there's a requirement under
house bill 154 that at least one third
of the
units
uh be
designated as
affordable housing for households at 80
percent or less of the median
income in the region
and under house bill 104
they
they are eligible for tax relief for up
to 10 years
so
house bill 104 is more
sort of
affordable housing senate bill 102 is
more
renovating older housing stock so
they're similar but um
similar but different
not not identical
and and and they're not inconsistent
with each
other you chairman i i believe that the
bill number that
representative is um
referring to would be house bill 341
sponsored by representative
van bill required that local legislative
bodies permit the right
certain single family dwellings and
residential districts to be used for up
to four residential units
oh that was a yeah that that was an um
different
concept that that was something that
dealt with uh zoning requirements it
said it said you had to allow up to four
units uh
in areas that are zoned for single
family dwellings
and that and the house
that that bill did not make it through
the house
yes
um thank you mr chairman i had a
separate question not related to that
issue
thank you mr johnston for taking my
question it pertains to
part one
and line 25
and the
the area that i
want
more information on is with regard to
the establishment of tax relief
for
an owner of a property who significantly
improves
the quality condition and or use of an
existing residential structure so my
question is
what what what is the criteria for
significantly improving how is that
determining determination made what's
the criteria and by whom
is that current
that that would be determined by
the governing body
if you uh if you
continue down that page uh under
paragraph two starting on line 27 it
says the governing body
um shall designate the area
uh in which it applies and may establish
further may further establish criteria
for the public benefits goals and
measures that will determine the
eligibility of qualifying structures for
tax relief
so it would be it would be
the governing body that determines um
whether it uh
whether it is whether it satisfies the
requirements up above there
so therefore the governing body will um
determine the criteria and also evaluate
the fat criteria has been met in order
to
obtain the tax relief that's right
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
johnson i just want to make sure we
understand
get back to the issue
that representative piemonte raised
earlier
i think the bill that he was and i'd
like mr johnson to reaffirm this if i'm
right i think the bill that
representative pia monte was addressing
was knew was developing new things
and this bill
is not developing anything new these
existing structures
already are two family homes or already
have four units in them um and this is
simply making it um so that these these
existing buildings can have the benefit
of this
um tax exemption am i correct mr
johnston
uh
yes um
uh i'm
i'm just looking at house bill 154 right
now to confirm
i was referring to house the bill that
that
sent that representative van brought
forward three was it 340
the one that was killed in the house
um okay this is this is not that bill at
all this has got nothing to do with
creation of new housing this is just
and updating
what's already there yes this is this is
entirely different
in addition that house bill 341 was
really a zoning bill
this is a this is a tax relief bill so
uh they they really other than the fact
that they both had to do with housing
they're really not not uh related at all
thank you
okay um
and he was uh the sponsor of this a
section of this bill so perhaps we
should have him um give his testimony
before we hear from the public
yes i was going to him next
i see that you guys
yeah thank you chairman dolan i'm glad
to address uh part one
uh of
uh senate bill 102
uh
and as has been previously noted
part one
uh
is at on the amended
senate version that has
uh moved to your committee for further
consideration
um
let me walk you through the bill real
fast uh and i appreciate mr johnson's
uh
having to to answer a number of
questions he's done a good job so you're
already familiar with it but let me just
point out that on page one line
six and seven articulate that what's
being added here is uh rsa 79
e
uh section or paragraph four
b
so b is the new
sub-paragraph being added
the
modification that
is taking place to the existing statute
79e2 is described on page 1 lines 25
through 27
defining
what
a
residential property is
and then you go to page two
line nine
uh does describe then
uh
uh 79 e4b so there's a lot of a lot of
verbiage before you get to and here's
what's new
uh and so what's new
is uh allowing a town to or a
municipality to establish uh tax relief
on
uh
family homes not more than four units
that are at least 40 years in age
and that the town
city
must designate a residential property
revitalization zone
that governing body shall designate both
the area and establish criteria for the
public good
for that property improvement
and then
it
says that that property can be improved
and qualify only once every 20 years and
as has been previously noted it's a
minimum of five years of
relief on the improved valuation of the
property
and can be extended if there are
additional uh units added
as a result of the improvement and let
me give you a visual now
you got the
details of the bill but
um if you uh
were in downtown keene which
has the keene state college uh within
two blocks of our historic downtown
district
uh and uh
around the college over quite a number
of years had been college housing
evolving out of residential homes uh
allowing for those to be occupied
up to four units in those homes
um
then
over that period of 30 years or so 50
years
larger developers would have
developed close to the campus so that
you've got structures that have maybe
100 to 150 units in those buildings
now those residential homes are no
longer as suitable for the college
student housing they're not in as much
demand because of what the enrollment
may be at the college
and you've got residential
families units uh
a budding a property that may not have
been maintained to the same level as the
single family unit
next door to it and that is what we face
in keene
i'm sure as i drive through central
areas of towns and cities throughout the
state of new hampshire throughout my
district
that there are similar kinds of
situations
where uh homes uh can
uh
uh be brought back to their original
presence and and
more in keeping with the residential
character of of the neighborhood that
was originally established
uh and
uh and that that has tremendous value to
a community not just to the aborters but
to the entire community
because of preserving
the built stock and the historic nature
of communities
so that's what this bill is aiming to do
and i i'm not sure if mayor
george hansell
is
still
with us
at this point but
this bill while
mr johnston is familiar with it
because
it passed the
senate last year
it
got caught up in covet and never did
have its hearing in the house
but
it is a bill that
i appreciate the support of the
municipal association
and the efforts of
the mayor
and his staff to
help refine the bill and bring it to you
for your consideration so i i'll be glad
to answer any questions chairman dolan
thank you representative gilman you have
a question
yes
uh thank you representative for taking
my question thank you mr chair i was
just curious about the um how the year
the age of 40 came about
um
i mean
because
it we i didn't
we're not trying to match the historic
building definition okay
can i have a follow-up mr chair sure
um
my town has used the 79e for uh
uh commercial areas
um do you think that this will well i
guess you do think never mind
i'm done thank you representative
guthrie
thank you mr trump thank you for taking
my question
i may have missed it but
uh who determines what a designated
residential property
revitalization zone is and can it be
changed
and can it be one
of residents
the
thank you for the question
representative the governing body
of the municipality
will make that determination of what the
revitalization
revitalization zone is and yes you're
right it can uh move
uh it it could be
in one section of a town
uh
in in one
point in time and moved to another
section of
a town
for another period of time um
it could be a wide swath uh that
uh is
and it could be a more narrow swath
depending on
uh
the goals of the
town and municipality
yes does that mean i'm i happen to be a
selectman in a challenge tom hampstead
uh
could it be possible that that zone
could be the whole town and if the
governing party
felt that this
was worthwhile
on a town-wide basis
they
could determine that that the town is a
zone
and uh set up an application for anybody
uh doing this type of work
uh if uh in fact
that was the way
yes a town could make that determination
representative power thank you mr
chairman um and thank you
for letting me pose my question
this is enabling legislation and
uh city or economy adopt this by a vote
of the legislative body is it that by a
majority vote or some form of a super
majority
no it's i think it would be a majority
vote mr johnson is probably here and
much more familiar but it's it's not
anticipated that there's uh
any
uh
that's my familiarity with 79e in
general
uh that it does not require
uh it just requires a majority vote of
the municipality
thank you mr chair thank you senator
khan for taking my question this
is
a legislation that kind of helps
facilitate the new market tax credit and
uh
opportunities on all those
opportunities to revitalize uh
older building
into a housing or
enabling it
to make it more um
environmentally friendly
am i correct
um so
this
a provides an incentive that
without having to have that
qualification a town could
could provide
the incentive and let me
just qualify it too that this incentive
is fairly small i don't think that this
will and and just imagine
uh
the
i believe it's seven and a half percent
of the improved valuation
uh over time so a fifty thousand
dollar
uh
renovation would would wind up
uh not being ted
let me try this again
on a 35 tax rate a 50 000 improvement
uh
would would wind up uh creating a
about a fifteen thousand dollar
incentive
uh and then that would be distributed
over a five-year period so it's it's
it's an improvement uh to in but but
clearly uh
people are are still bearing the
significant cost of the improvement
there's no subsidy here
representative porter
thank you mr chair i'm going to see if i
can remember my question now um so
the governing body um
designates the revitalization area but
any tax
um
tax breaks for it have to be approved by
the legislative body at town meeting or
some other way is that right
representative senator grant
well it would be the governing body of
the municipality so uh
in the case of uh a city of keene i i
know that it could be the city
uh
uh without uh uh necessarily having to
go to a vote
uh
edit it
there wouldn't be a warrant article on
this
okay so
yeah i'm just confused then because any
time that our community has had brought
this forward under um this section of
the law 79e it's always come to a vote
at town meeting whether to allow it or
not so i'm just con
maybe it was just a super
cautious
community but i understood that in order
to give him a tax break you needed to
get the approval of of the town
maybe
mr chairman and thank you for asking and
pursuing that question uh representative
porter right uh if the chairman can see
that uh mr johnston is
still present he's probably more
qualified to answer that question he's
still here
uh
you can hear me i assume um
yes uh representative porter is right
the the in a town the town meeting would
need to adopt this section
to to authorize the granting of the tax
relief it would then be up to the
governing body the board of selectmen to
determine
the you know what what the area is and
um
and what the what the criteria are
thank you
thank you and uh question from uh
representative guthrie all right i'm
just gonna say the same thing
[Music]
okay they've got three weights off are
there any other final questions before
you close the hearing
okay seeing none um
hearing on senate bill 102
a couple of administrative notes
we're going to
for executive session at 12 45
so uh get some lunch and enjoy your
lunch but for those of you
who are not present in the love
and are on the zoo call one of our
rules especially those of you who are
all right uh guess
subject today
that
when you are
during the executive session i need to
be able to see you live
so uh please note no avatars or no
skilled pictures
uh just uh
please make sure you click on a live
image
or else we'll have a problem
recording your votes
so thank you for that
and uh we'll reconvene at
12 45
and thank you very much and those those
of you who are online are in the room
remember these mics sometimes stay hot
so be careful
what's up
um
there it is
minimize this
that's the zoom thing
i'll go over to this
representative mcbride your mic is on
this
50.
so
you
oh
okay
oh that's how i do it
at the end of vendor
foreign
[Music]
or something like that
we're hearing a lot of conversation
yeah we haven't started yet but uh
people are saying is going
over the airways
well that's good you want me to mute
this
up there
um
all right we're going to get ready to
start the executive session
you came here
it's too noisy and
so many conversations
okay guys
yes i am
i'm not i'm not seeing i'm i'm thinking
i'm paul ayer sorry
facebook
okay we're going to uh we're going to
proceed
in executive session in just a moment
just
for your own uh edification and your
notes that you may have been taking over
the last
week or so
we're going to
exact the bills in the same order that
we heard them
so we'll start with
84 and then go to 86
then 88
then 52
and 87 and 106.
you ready want me to repeat that or
can you repeat that mr chair please
we'll start with 84
and go to 86
and then 88
102.
and the representative here can i get
you to start your video
so
please be patient because we have one
member that's uh
[Music]
oh there he is good
we got everybody now okay
okay uh we have everybody this is the
municipal and
county government uh back just back from
lunch
and we are going to go into executive
section and
consider
the six bills that we've got from the
senate
started last week we looked at three
bills
senate bills 84 86 and 88
and today we heard
three more bills 52 87 and 102. and
we'll go through them in that order
uh one at a time
chairman yes
i make a motion we vote ought to pass
on senate billy before
okay
uh
discussion among the committee
representative gallagher
so i'd just like to clarify for the
record
um since the
purple paint amendment
um
that
was discussed last week got ruled
non-germane that means that i can't
introduce it now correct
that's correct so we're just voting
so we're just voting on the village
district public bodies
language then yes
we'll be voting on it uh unamended okay
thanks
is there any other discussion on the
bill
from the committee
seeing that i'm asked the uh clerk to
call the role
representative p monty
yeah
question yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie yes
representatives yes
representative mcbride
representative
yeah i'm mute uh
yeah sorry about that yes
representative
yes
excuse me are you addressing me
representative vale no i'm sorry
representative
yes
representative perch
representative gilman
yes
representative maturity yes
representatives davis
yes
representative
sorry i'm having difficulty with my uh
internet
so we're asking for you to vote on on
senate bill 84
yes no no
oh no
representative phil
representative dale did you get on
youtube
no
representative gracie
yes
representative gallagher
uh yes
chairman
okay
to the clerk
the uh
the house clerk and if we can is right
any objection to going on the consent
calendar if i could go on 17
no no
i mean let me go on consent i was one of
the nos i don't have any report to make
okay i will check and if i can i will
put that on consensus
thank you
so next is uh senator bill 87.
mr chair i have an amendment
sorry 86 i'm sorry 86. mr chair i have
an amendment to offer on senate bill 86
is make your amendments
thank you it's the chair we need to have
a motion first of all to pass before we
can move an amendment
i i think that's i think that's
incorrect i believe we can
we vote on the amendment and then
the next motion will be not the past as
i mentioned
um
you do need to have a motion first on
the on the main bell before you can have
an amendment to it that's correct
yeah we need to pass motion first
then we we ought to pass on the
amendment is the rules that i've always
seen before you you don't vote on them
on your on the
on the original motion you just have to
have to have a motion and then you move
to amend it
on senate building six
second
okay there's a motion not to pass
[Music]
correct thank you
would you like me to speak to my
amendment
yes
thank you very much it is amendment
1404h
it amends only part three
of
sb86 and it changes the language that
states
that
municipalities
may not prohibit
certain types of
heating systems
and it changes that to make it possible
or make it
make it there a prohibition against
cities
forcing structures built prior to the
passage of the law
should it pass
from
changing or updating their heating
systems should those municipalities pass
an ordinance regarding heating systems
so it extends the issue of choice even
further
okay
hey is there any uh
any questions about that amendment
okay so now we're voting on the
abandonment
and uh since there is no discussion i'll
ask the
clerk to call the roll on your head
this is a
sba
tp remember 202
four each
group said p.m martin
no
clerk folks no
representative tripp now
representative guthrie
representative gonzalez no
representative mcbride
no
representative melvin no
representative here
no
representative power no
representative reporter
uh president
yes
representative bridge
representative gilman
yes
representative majority yes
representative stevens yes
yes
representative
representative gallagher
yes
and chairman
no
motion fails 10 tonight
okay
what's the numbers
h
[Music]
thank you mr chair
um i just want to have some statistics
here that i wanted to share with the
committee before they consider this
amendment
the median list price of a house in new
hampshire
is 399 000
the median sales price of a house in new
hampshire and this is the most recent is
382 000
the inventory of houses for sale has
decreased 66 percent
from a year ago
the average rent in new hampshire as of
december 2020 was seventeen hundred
dollars a month
the median rent for a one bedroom
apartment is two hundred sixty nine
dollars a month
the median rent for a two bedroom
apartment is one thousand five hundred
twenty five dollars a month the median
rent for a three-bedroom apartment is
1795 dollars a month
a healthy vacancy rate for rentals is 5
hours as 1.7 percent
i'm urging you to please vote no on this
amendment
this section of the bill is a benign
section of the bill that will allow will
give you municipalities who choose to do
so some tools in their toolbox to help
them manage any development that they
might want we have a crisis of housing
in this state
we can't
keep ignoring it or kicking the can down
the road so i urge you please this
section of the bill
costs no money is benign simply putting
it into
law so that it's there if if towns and
cities choose to use it
thank you
thank you mr chair mr chair i work in a
grocery store in lebanon new hampshire
we have
12 cash registers we have on average two
cashiers to run those registers
people from all over all walks of life
shop in that grocery store rich people
poor people in between people
the cashiers and the people who work in
the store cannot find a place to live
can you tell me how this is good for new
hampshire business to continue this
restrictive
wrong-headed in my view and i'm sorry to
use such a strong word but i must use it
because i've confronted every day with
my
colleagues why is it sensible for
business
to continue using this approach when the
people that the businesses rely on
to staff their operations simply cannot
live here anymore
yes i did uh thank you maybe
um
it's it's very similar to what
representatives davis just asked but
what is the can is someone willing to
give the rationale for eliminating this
well uh
okay
just plain tough
i'm sorry did somebody give a rationale
i didn't i didn't
uh
did you explain it just cleans up the
bill
cleans up the bill did i hear that
correctly what does that exactly mean
representative
i'm not going to get into long details
with the amendment
i expect everybody to read it i'm sorry
we can't hear you
i said i'm not going to get into long
detail about this
i put the amendment out there
uh representative uh
calendar did you have did you have any
uh no i may have just
gestured in reaction to something that
was being said that wasn't an actual
hand raise
uh
anyone else
have additional discussion if we would
vote on the
amendment yes representative manager
thank you mr chair
uh i too would like the explanation i do
have the amendment but this is the exact
session isn't this where we discuss or
uh
support or oppose what we are trying to
bring the amendment
yes it is i believe representative
gave you his explanation i understand
that some of you may not
thank you mr chair uh i would just like
to um point out uh what representative
porter had brought brought up with her
statistics and that we've been hearing
and
myself as a slip board member in exeter
have been hearing how hard it is for
people to find a place to live in town
and
uh and work in town so and we've heard
this even from the governor that there
is a housing shortage and so i don't
understand why
what is a very usable and optional a
local decision
uh would be removed from this bill
yeah thank you and you know
the the second largest city in the state
we here we have over 2 000 housing
shortages 2 000 units shortage we are
negative 5
of available market and we have students
we have a workforce
and it is just incredibly i get called
on a daily basis to see if there's a
room to let
and when we are in the middle of the
crisis
and we
as a municipal and county government
are we really addressing the need of our
constituents
and that's my question and i think this
enables at least gives some kind of a
leeway some
tool
for the local government
local municipalities to
address the needs in their communities
and i
i just cannot
understand why
this is being removed
all right
thank you representative
thank you mr chair um i'll be voting
against the amendment i'm i'm uh i echo
everything that my
uh that the other representatives have
said here my friends have said here i
recognize the
unanimous vote that this came out with
from the senate
from election law and municipal affairs
as a as a tool to address affordable
housing in new hampshire
i recognize the fact that we have yet to
vote out anything that addresses
we have yet to support um anything that
addresses affordable housing out of
municipal and county government uh we're
doing our best with with each bill and
each one keeps getting voted down so i i
just i'm not sure how
eliminating this entire section cleans
up a bill
so i will be voting against the
amendment and continue to support all
efforts to increase affordable housing
in new hampshire thank you
thank you representatives
thank you mr chair um
i consider representative pimanti my
friend
and good colleague but i do take
exception to his language on cleaning up
this bill
i see nothing unclean
about a provision in a bill that
facilitates municipalities from adopting
policies that will increase their level
of housing for all of their citizens and
i repeat all of their citizens in
lebanon we are home to the dartmouth
hitchcock medical center
we have nurses we have neurologists we
have surgeons who cannot find places to
live
so when we're talking about cleaning up
a bill i want us to be very clear that
what we're cleaning up
is our own ability to be taken care of
and to and take care of professionals in
our communities
is
[Music]
okay sb 86 remember 2021
what's up your margin yes
yes representative
yes
representative guthrie yes represent los
alas yes
mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative porter
no
representative burch
no representatives governments
no
representative
representative davis
no
problem
representative
no
representative press
representative gallagher
no
chairman dole yes
motion passes tense tonight
mr chairman yeah
second
did you want to have any discussion i'm
sorry yes i did
thank you
so we have uh a motion and a second
to pass the bill
as amended is there a discussion at this
point
additional discussion
yes uh representative statements
so
realizing that my comments will not make
any difference i wish to make them
anyway what we have now in this amended
bill is a bill that is a gift to
commercial developers and a gift to the
fossil fuel industry that is my only
comment
thank you
is there any further comment
on the
motion to ask that event
seeing no further
requests to discuss and ask the clerk
representative kia martin
workforce yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yes
representative rosales yes
representative mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative power yes
no
representative burch no
representative gilman
no
representative majority
now
representative davis no
reference senator bank foodie no
representative
no
representative gallagher
chairman dole yes
uh otp as amended passes 10 tonight
definitely not a candidate for the
consensus
no there will be a minority report mr
chair i'm not sure who will send it to
you but one of us will
do you have a deadline for these reports
um
i believe it's uh thursday morning
maybe
wednesday closing business is that
reasonable
that's reasonable thank you appreciate
it
and please send them to me
i have to approve all the uh
[Music]
all right next up is uh
senate bill 88
uh that was the bill um
about
several things
built but it
has
the broad range broadband infrastructure
and regulation of these utility poles
attachments and
setting up communications committees
among multiple times
mr chair
i move out to pass on senate bill 88
second
is that representative status and second
step it is
thank you okay
that reporter made a motion
is there any discussion on the bill
i would like to speak to my motion
i believe this bill had pretty strong
support in the senate we know we need to
do something
to expand broadband in this state there
are many places even within cities and
well-populated towns that don't have
access to
significant broadband
this bill seems to take care of those
needs or is at least a step in the right
direction so
i urge my colleagues to support
the ought to pass motion
this should not be a partisan issue
thank you
any other discussion on the on the
motion
of what facts
seeing none
an
yes
representative
representative guthrie yes
representative los alas yes
representative mcbride
yes
representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative power yes
representatives davis yes
representative
yes
representative rossi yes
gallagher
yes
and chairman yes
19 to 0.
without objection i'll put that in
consent
all right
okay we're halfway done and i just uh
let me say that
thank you all for staying live on your
uh
on your computers and i just want to ask
you
okay so
now we're going to go to
one of the bills we created today that's
uh senate bill 52
senate bill 52 is uh
talks about the
exclusions and ordinances
when we have uh
an attempt to override a tax cap
mr chairman yes i'd like to make a
motion yes not to pass on senate bill 52
okay there's a motion by representative
i believe the motion was made by
representative power
yes didn't i say that said
representative
i'm sorry
you're right
i'm looking right at her it is
representative
okay is there any discussion on
representative powers
when
if i want to make a motion of itl is
this time or no no if the motion fails
to otp then it would be
then in order to make a new motion
uh so uh
ask the clerk to call the vote
yes
look folks yes representative trump yes
representative governor yes
representative los alas yes
representative mcbride
yes representative melvin yes
representative here
yes
representative power yes
reporter
no
representative burch no
representative gilman no
representative majority
no
representative stevens no
representative
no
representative grossly no
representative gallagher
no
chairman gold yes
ocean passes 10th and act
there will be a minority report
okay thank you
and the majority
right
i'm
[Music]
senate bill 87 this is a reminder
on the bus legislation
about uh conducting
a musical finance as it relates to water
funds
uh
i would
move it out to pass
not the past is there a second
it's a discussion on the motion
representative guthrie yes
representative los alas yes
representative mccry
yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
yes
representative power yes
representative porter yeah
representative burch
yes
president
representative
[Music]
yes
representative
yes representative gallagher
yes
chairman
yeah
19-0
without objection i'll put that on the
consent calendar
okay and the last bill we're going to
talk about and that's the last build
of our session so congratulations to you
all we made it we've made it through the
second half
i know all the results aren't
what
many of you individually
hoped for but
i think it's an accomplishment that
we've gotten through this far
uh and
[Music]
until we meet um general session the
first week of june
you all
you all have that calendar i assume
if not i will put out a reminder
meeting next
which will be
at the ball field again
over in bedford
i believe it's the
thursday and friday
the first week of june
so uh
we're now up to senate bill 102
which is the uh which is enabling
legislation
about
residential property
rebate revitalization and tax exemption
for certain renewable energy and energy
storage systems
uh is there is there a motion
yes mr should i move out to pass on
senate bill 102. second mr chair
representative porter makes a motion on
the past and representative mcbride
seconds is the discussion on the motion
yes i'd like to discuss my motion yes
please go ahead
um
again i think you wrapped it up pretty
well this is enabling legislation it
gives communities um some more tools to
help them um
develop what they have in their in their
town
and city um and it helps with um storage
it helps
storing
the wrong word it helps encourage um the
use of renewable energy as well so i
think it's a good bill that's enabling
and helps people out
thank you is there any further
discussion yes representative
thank you mr chair uh i be
representative porter said everything i
was going to say and i wasn't fast
enough to take my hand down
thank
thank you mr chair uh i'm really happy
to see that this is catching up with
what we need in our communities and
moving new hampshire forward in the
constituents with renewable sustainable
energy as well as
housing and restoration in all
encompassing to keep the character of
new hampshire i'm
pleased to see this go forward i hope
it's a
bipartisan
vote thank you
yes sir
yeah
this is a another
sorry
i i remember last year we had many
exemptions
i still can't hear you
can you hear me now
um
last year we had uh many exemptions
and they were put uh
to task
and we felt that maybe uh that was an
opportunity to put them all together and
have a subcommittee to vote on
well this is another exemption
and what makes this exemption better
than the others we had last year
i feel that something like this should
be put to uh another subcommittee
and uh see what they can come up with on
this because
it's just uh
you know
i'm not gonna
this could be an end round around the uh
for another exemption that the taxpayers
are going to have to pay for
so that's what i have to say about that
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative piamanchi for reminding
us of that committee that was held there
were a number of bills that had to do
with veterans
um
and disabled veterans tax exemptions and
credits and that was that was we put
those bills aside because there was a
subcommittee that was looking at the
issue of how to deal with all the
different exemptions that people had
for proposing for veterans
the
tax
exemptions in this bill
is just extending
it's just extending the definition of a
revitalization zone to allow what we
already have
to be used in more circumstances so i
think there are different kinds of
exemptions
um
the permanency of a veteran's exemptions
forever
the tax
tax
exemption for revitalization zones
goes away after a number of years um
there are different sorts of exemptions
so that's how i look at it it's yes
other taxpayers pick up the cost when we
give an elderly exemption or a veteran's
exemption or a disabled
exemption but
in this case most cases the exemptions
don't go away in this one they do
representative
gilman did you know
yes thank you mr chair um i would agree
with representative porter's comments uh
the last uh
term or whenever that we had a number of
exemption bills they were all for
or most of them were for elderly
exemptions and
exemptions from school taxes in
particular
exemptions lowering the age of
[Music]
elderly exemption they were things that
would be permanent from here on out the
town would define it but
but from that period that it becomes
active then those exemptions you could
apply for them every year with this
tax relief program
the governing body defines a set period
of time
where the
tax is not exempted
it's just the valuation stays
uh at the at the cost or at the price
when the property was
as it was
and then the valuation increases as the
property gets improved and so when the
the period of time
that that
tax relief is in place
the taxpayer has a flat rate but once
it's improved then the valuation goes up
and the town is earning it more in tax
value so i don't see these at the same
adult
excuse me at all because one gives you
valuation gives you extra value and more
income in the end whereas the others
that we heard before just exempted the
taxes outright and left the burden on
the rest of us paying taxes
thank you uh
thank you mr chair um and to piggyback
representative gilman says this then
provides that just little bit of relief
in in a time where
the affordability of housing
not affordable housing but the
affordability of housing based on our
ever increasing tax rates
you're giving somebody just a little bit
of relief at the discretion of the town
so i i
i see this as not being um
i i see this as being transparent open
and honest about the availability for
just this one little potential
um where local authority still exists
um where full disclosure is required
uh and i and i don't see how there could
be any um any i'm i'm hesitant to use
the the the term but uh end arounds here
so
i i would hope that the committee would
would support this bill and
and provide that little bit of relief
for our communities thank you
thank you representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
make a couple of comments
uh as we go along with this bill
particularly about section one i always
like the word may when i see a wooden a
as a selectmen it makes me feel a little
more comfortable and i think that this
uh bill particularly section uh one
uh
gives a
two byte
situation where i think they have to go
to the legislative party to
uh okay where the zone is going to be
and i then they the individual select
board would have to uh vote on each
individual
uh item
or request rather
and i particularly like the fact that it
looks like
uh the interpretation is good as you
could even have
the revitalization zone the whole town
so that would be able to
have the selectmen and the town
nitpicked if you will
uh areas where they need the help
particularly if you don't have just one
area that needs redu development but you
have pockets within the community so i'm
going to vote for the bill i
i hope it gets some use
and that people use discretion
has
been concerned about
another abatement so
but i think it's a tool that's uh i'd
like to have him right private as a
builder
representative porter made a promotion
to otp
house senator bill 102 is there any
further discussion on that motion
let me take a book mr
chair i just
had my hand up yes go ahead
yeah um
thank you thank you for recognizing me i
think this gives uh new hampshire
communities a chance to revitalize their
old mill buildings buildings that are
not paying taxes in terms of uh their
communities and this will give incentive
that way and really address that and i
would really appreciate or would like to
see my colleagues on both sides to
support us thank you
thank you any last uh
comments before we take a vote
see none
mr clerk would you call the roll
okay uh otp and sv102
representative pmrt no
collectors yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yes
representative los alas
yes
representative mcbride
representative melvin now
representative here
no
representative power no
representative porter
yes
representative burch
representative gilman
yes
representative majority yes
representatives davis
yes
representative mcafoohy
representative
yes
representative grassy
representative gallagher
yes
chairman dolan
i wish you passed this 15-4
15-4 well thank you that was our last
bill
uh it passes uh again i'd like to say
thank you representatives dale and
gracie for joining us
uh it was a pleasure having you
and
to all my colleagues on both sides of
the aisle look forward to seeing you
first week in june
and have a healthy and safe place
thank you thank you mr chair
goodbye everybody